often when a friend is on the show i
feel bad bringing it up because you know
you kind of think life has moved on it
doesn't do that but you
do bring it up you do recreate things
on your socials like the famous uh
turkey scene
uh this you know and you know yeah
so you decided to really do this
anything for the gram
yes i did put oh god i'm such an idiot i
i don't you know people say aren't you
supposed to be kind of mysterious or
aloof or it's like that's isn't it
instagram just to be a yourself so i'm
pretty goofy but yes i decided it was
thanksgiving i was going to put a turkey
on my head and that's not a real turkey
i didn't know where to get one like that
so i did excuse me to all the vegans i
put a real turkey on my head oh my god
we got you guys when i tell you it was
so gross you tell us why we watch this
because it's not as easy as you'd think
no uh here we go
uh obviously vegan discretion advised
so now what have you put on your head
a towel and then i also had like a
little plastic oh girl oh no
[Laughter]
but now you had a special butcher in to
help okay so i when scream there's a
girl named melissa barrera who i love
and we became really good friends she
came over with her husband who's a
butcher
that's what it looked like after then i
ate it
[Music]